Представьте, что Пайта можно учить не как учебник, а как
настоящую игру, где каждый новый навык — это новый уровень.
Именно для этого мы создали Пайглэс.
Сегодня у новичка есть тысячи видео, кроссов и роликов по камину.
Но проблема не в хатке информации, а в том, что ты смотришь теорию,
копируешь код, запускаешь его и получаешь ошибку.
Сейчас я просто не понимаю, что делать дальше.
Поэтому Пайглэс создан для школьников и начинающих программистов,
которым не нужен не еще один курс, а среда, в которой хочется
продолжать учиться.
В Пайглэс обучение превращается в квест.
Ты проходишь в визуальные уроки, сразу пишешь настоящий код на
Python и прямо в браузере.
Ты можешь зайти на ноутбуке и еще раз на телефоне.
Запускаешь код, проходишь тесты и можешь буквально по шагам
увидеть, как выполняется программа и как меняются переменные.
А если ты застрял, подключайся и иментор.
Но он не просто выдает готовый ответ, он дает подсказку, дает
направление и помогает тебе самому прийти к правильному решению.
И задания дают новую практику в зависимости от ученика и его
уровня.
Также, чтобы обучение не превращалось в обучении по обучению,
за прогресс ты каждый раз получаешь xp и монеты.
Открываешь достижение, выполняешь ежедневные квесты, проходишь
в миль игры,
сражаешься с боссами и можешь даже соревноваться с другими игроками.
Там даже есть рейтинг, так как оно не игра, но по прогрессу.
И самое главное, это уже не просто идеи на слайде, в прототипе,
который мы создали недавно.
Поэтому уже выполняется прямо в браузере, через PowerDite.
В респонденте я работаю через вайерпас и им это через Jimny IP,
а реалтайм механика через socket.io.
Моя цель очень простая, сделать так, чтобы первый сайт человека
с прогрессу.
Пограммирование вызывало не:
Ээээ, это слишком сложно.
Ааа, я хочу пройти в следующий уровень.
Пайбэс.
А свой программирование на прайдинге играя.